Now that we've seen how file systems work, we turn
to several optimizations that help make it fast, since most storage
devices tend to be slow. We'll first discuss some software
optimizations and then turn to hardware. If you're first reaction is,
let's use a cache, then you're on the right track.
Indeed most operating systems do use free portions of main memory
as a cache for the much slower mass storage device. Statistics
vary on this sort of thing over time as technologies changes,
but by most measurements, memory is as much as 100,000
times faster than disk for random access. Would use the
portion of memory used as a cache for disc, the
unified buffer cache, a name it earned for some obscure historical
reasons. The terminology here can be a little confusing. So
I'm going to emphasize that we're talking about in memory caching of
the contents of the disc, not the RAM on the
disc controller that the device controller here might use. When data
is read from disc, is stored in this unified buffer
cache so that subsequent reads can find it there. Instead
of having to bother the disk again, because disk access
is often sequential. It is common also to read ahead in
a file, loading up subsequent blocks to main memory so
that is there when the application needs it. Writing to
disk is usually done with the write back policy. The
change is made only in the unified buffer cache at first.
And the page is marked as dirty. The slower operation
of writing the data to the disk is postponed until
some more opportune time. New files can also be created
and stored in the unified buffer cache. If a file has
a very short life span, writing to the disk might
not be necessary at all. The existence of the end memory
cache. Means that a call to write isn't a guarantee
that the data is changed on the disk and will persist.
The changes are only reflected in memory. The advantage is
that the program gets to resume faster and get on with
its work. The downside is that if the system crashes
before the write has been made to disk then changes will
be lost. If you really do want to make sure that
changes are reflected on disk, need to call fsync or msync
to flush out the unified buffer cache. The write-back policy of
the buffer cache is also the reason that operating systems will
warn you not to move storage devices without
ejecting it first. It needs a chance to
flush the buffer cache and any dirty pages
so that changes will be reflected on the device.